contre qui denis brogniart at il fait
part de son dégoût
allez j'ai posé la question à des
contrôles radars si vous payez contre
les oiseaux de l'île qui font leurs
besoins sur sa cabane contre les
candidats manipulateur contre ceux qui
menacent les aventuriers ou contre les
téléspectateurs qui mangent des pizzas
dans l'émission il aime pas fan de ning
ce qui m'énerve qu'ils d'aventuriers et
bien contre ceux qui menacent et dans
turion à voir si valérie bénaïm la
meilleure élève de la classe encore
donné une bonne réponse
regardez alors je voudrais vous dire mon
dégoût ma consternation
ma colère aussi devant les messages
haineux scandaleux reçu par certains
aventuriers je les ai cité
régis inès charlotte alexandra et bien
sûr auparavant hamad
mais alors dans quel monde vit-on
comment peut-on menacé de mort insultes
et promettre le pire à des aventuriers
de koh lanta
ces messages sont l'oeuvre d'une infime
minorité des grilles de jaloux des gens
qui méritent a minima le mépris et le
pire c'est que tous ou presque sévices
sous couvert d'anonymat
son courage de leurs propos en se
cachant derrière un pseudo bidon et
j'adore denis brogniart même patrice
vénère on dirait qu'il va donner une
épreuve de koh lanta
qu'il s'agisse tout ça dans l'anonymat
non mais alors le braille de koh lanta
ce vendredi a beaucoup fait réagir sur
les réseaux à tel point que certains
candidats ont reçu des menaces de mort
et des insultes
c'est notamment le cas de régis et inès
depuis il ya eu énormément de réactions
la société production donc un boulet et
vu denis brogniart en passant par
d'anciens candidats de jeu on vous lit
puis tout ça pour quoi ils ont été
menacés regarde
vendredi soir dernier sam était éliminée
de koh lanta l'île des héros une
décision qui est loin d'avoir fait
l'unanimité sur les réseaux et pour une
fois les échanges entre les internautes
sont un peu dépassées la sempiternelle
guerre des clans propre programme
certains d'entre eux très en colère
après cette élimination ont même franchi
allègrement la ligne jaune en proférant
des menaces de mort à l'encontre des
autres aventuriers sur instagram inès
victimes de ces attaques a décidé
d'exprimer sa tristesse vie
le mans très émue elle déclare axes
[Musique]
mentionnés
même chose pour régis qui avait reçu des
messages menaçants directement sa
famille
j'espère que tes enfants vont mourir je
vais te retrouver tu étais fille de
violentes attaques qui ont fait réagir
denis brogniart lors d'un live instagram
l'animateur du jeu a déclaré je voudrais
vous dire mon dégoût ma consternation la
colère aussi devant les messages haineux
scandaleux reçu par certains aventuriers
je les ai cité
régis inès charlotte alexandra et bien
sûr auparavant hamad
mais alors dans quel monde vit-on
comment peut-on menacé de mort insultes
et promettre le pire à des aventuriers
de koh lanta
très agacé il a poursuivi ses messages
sont l'oeuvre d'une infime minorité des
grilles de jaloux des gens qui méritent
a minima le mépris une colère qui est
aussi celle de la société alp qui
produit le jeu face à ces menaces
elle a décidé de saisir le procureur de
la république de paris des propos et
menaces dont ont été victimes plusieurs
concurrents en attendant et pour calmer
le jeu sam a lui aussi accepté de
prendre la parole sur les réseaux pour
demander aux internautes de garder leur
calme
on m'a fait part de toute la violence
tous les messages très violent et la
haine qui a été déversé à mes camarades
aventure une élimination qui prend des
proportions démesurées
moi je le kiffe ce sage sais pas pour
vous mais j'adore ça
j'avais vu la peau calme alors il est
tellement aimé d'ailleurs que c'est ça
que voilà car engendré voilà ces menaces
de mort est vrai qu'il ya des gens qui
sont tellement dans le programme
voilà qui dit voilà ils en veulent
énormément aux autres candidats je pense
que tout ça va se tasser un mine de rien
voilà faux pas je pense pas que ça se
soit voilà c'est ce soir extrêmement
c'est grave de faire ça mais je pense
que ça va se passer
voilà c'est damien mercereau moi qui m'a
mis au courant de tv mag qui m'a parlé
de ça qui est sur l' enquête et il nous
donnera d'autres infos prochainement oui
jean michel oui on rigole quand vous
terminez chaque jour l'émission par la
télé c'est que la télé c'est vrai cette
phrase là pour tout son sens la télé
c'est dans le jeu ces divertissements
les jo et devient tout à coup tout ça
c'est une ode la télé ça s'est arrêté
aujourd'hui arrête soir était ce truc
c'est incroyable tu as raison mon chéri
je suis d'accord oui mathieu bah oui
mais surtout ce que devrait de
comprendre denis brogniart c'est que à
l'époque on recevait des sacs entiers
les animateurs de courrier alors il y
avait des revues scientifiques négatif
mais eiter du fallait quand même qu'ils
prennent à stylo qu'il écrit qu'ils
mettent en ligne amiens c'était un
effort aujourd'hui à +7 efforts à faire
en ligne est insultes quelqu'un mais je
pense qu'il ya pas plus de enter de jean
débit les insultes aujourd'hui qu'il ya
vingt ans c'est juste que l'on leur
donne la parole en un clic